quick story I want to mention for you
this is the height of irony tony Perkins
is president of the Family Research
Council this is an organization
considered an anti LGBT hate group by
the Southern Poverty Law Center Tony
Perkins
one of the most fervent anti gay
activists that this country has seen was
left homeless by the destructive
flooding that has ravaged southern
Louisiana killing more than 10 people
destroying tens of thousands of homes
Perkins of course has previously claimed
that God uses natural disasters like
hurricanes and flooding to punish people
for sinning including gay people for
being gay
he now has had his own home destroyed
apparently by the Lord Almighty what
does this tell us Louis it tells us that
if he's right then he is gay or a gay
sympathizer and he's been hiding it all
along yeah or it tells us absolutely
nothing well he was asked about this
right and his explanation was that this
was not this particular flood right so
now that it's applying to tony perkins
who says typically God sends floods to
punish gay people for him it wasn't at
all about any sin or homosexuality or
anything like that but it was quote an
incredible encouraging spiritual
exercise to take you to the next level
in your walk with an almighty and
gracious God who does all things well of
course when other people suffer
misfortune at the hands of natural
disasters it's punishment for sinning
when he suffers it it's a test sent by
God to make him even stronger and rest
assured the the gay people who were
affected by the same flight yeah for
them it was punishing oh absolutely
yeah yeah yeah can God's gaydar be wrong
if God is all-knowing and all-powerful
and you buy into this type of nonsense
Jason could God's gaydar be
miscalibrated so to speak it's certainly
not not really not not does not fall
within the worldview of someone like
tony perkins that there would be any
kind of mistake made to be clear I don't
wish harm upon people I don't wish for
flooded floods to destroy people's homes
but I don't think I'm a bad person for
recognizing the irony am i no no this is
a
this is something that clearly he needs
to now explain to his his sheep oh yeah
and they're not even gonna think about
it unfortunately they're just gonna
believe everything he says and maybe
they even forgot about his punishment
comments before maybe they've been
tested to become stronger by God because
they oppose homosexuality so God has
picked them to say you're so good for
opposing homosexuality I'm gonna send a
flood to your area in order to actually
strengthen you even more and of course
we know God works in mysterious ways
they're very mysterious ways but the
good news is the more money you give to
this guy yeah the better more God will
like you yeah